yes i'm here wish you guys started
okay
so we start yeah it's all yours okay
thank you
so alright i will talk now about
multi-stage program when we have many
stages
and we need in order to do something
positive we need some structure
because the original thing that we have
here almost
hopeless if i don't assume anything
about this process
all right it's i
i needed to look at this functional and
it would quickly become unmanageable at
all
there's no there's no simple concept of
the state here for example
what does it mean
also some people say that okay so one of
the classical approach
everybody knows about that using
dynamical programming
and this is where the progress is
i i try to explain this scenario
approach which
walk reasonably okay with
random generation e for two stage
does not work in multi-stage so at least
it's not clear
because the computational complexity
grow also exponentially with number of
stages
so now if i
want to use dynamical programming
which has some specific form here there
are some different questions
okay so let me i i think now that
everybody knows what demonical problem
is because this is
one of the main tools of all that
so let me remind you that this is denote
this
history of the process one also can
write it in terms of filtration but
it's more intuitive right and one we can
write dynamical equations
and this is the way how we can write
them in very general way
very general it's not very useful but
conceptually
it is like that what we do here
right uh when i talk the expected value
we decompose the problem
into stages into this what is called
value function of course the row
functions
and you see this the whole process here
of decision is conditional
observe this realization of the data and
we make the decision
right because that we decompose that
taken this conditional expectation
at the first stage eventually the first
stage one has to solve
that problem where this is the
corresponding value function
if it is two stage we have just one
right this is what
i formulate here now
is it really any useful to write this
canonical equation like that this
dynamical question summarizing you all
know
will know now summarize what will look
at the particular point and look
value of happened in the future
unconditionally
at this point it's not useful at all
because
if they
they have one can use how to compute
this expectation one discretization i
will talk about that
but one of the main questions here how
can i
put in the computer this function
how because i when i go backward in time
as everybody is doing it
right that i have to keep
my function values of that only in very
simple cases
it's possible to write analytically so
if i want to do it like that
i have to remember this it's function of
many many variables
how you can represent multiply a
function of many variables in the
computer it's not trivial at all
in fact it's impossible if this number
of this
variables are very large so the first
the basic assumption that we make now
right this it has different name that
the process
is independent from one stochastically
from one stage to another
let's call it stage-wise independent it
doesn't need to be iit
but at least it's independent this is
probably the simplest post okay if i
want to model that this is a sequence of
random vector this problem
the simplest way to do that if i want to
model in that case i need only need to
know
marginal distributions of every vector
i don't need to remember the past and
indeed
it's not difficult to prove in that case
right that the so-called value functions
here this right expression
they don't depend on the past
observations
when you look with control when you look
at control
and also to less and it is
uh this is a very essential thing about
that
when they consider the noise they
consider this
as a noise or disturbances this so this
condition is independence is very
natural
here it's not so but let's follow when
it is you
now then my veil
this cross-to-go functions only depend
on that
uh it's possible to do more precise and
possible to introduce also concept of
state variables this is what i have to
remember
every time they make the decision and
the solution
is that so if
somehow i can compute
this these functions
and i can keep it in the computer
memory in the sense i solve the problem
because my optimal solution will be
given by this
sequence i can go forward generate my
data
this observations and every time support
seconds if i can solve that
i solve the problem now
still there are several questions one
ques obvious question
is this i said it's not natural
in any way because there is a markovian
type obstruction
i don't have much time to talk about
that sometimes it's possible to do
something
but suppose someone is quite yet
okay i have this decision variable this
is
what you can think about this is a state
it's also possible to to separate it
what is a called sometimes state
variables is what is local this is what
i have to remember
if i go from one stage to another okay
can i solve it so if it has dimension
hundred
or thousand and now it's not uncommon to
have this
it's still i have still this problem
it's a classical problem
of course of dimensionality and let me
say it's very clear
nobody nobody solved this problem of
course
so surprisingly in some cases
something possible to do which is almost
a miracle in my opinion
okay now this is i
listed here of this approach of
dynamical problem
in this second i'm saying a second
okay
so remember this what what is the
problem
one problem is i still have to compute
the expected value of that
this is the same as in two-stage case
what how can i do that i can
do discretization by saying something
not the card
it's the same thing and we have quite a
good idea
how many uh points we needed for
reasonable
i'll show you probably shall have tunnel
to show you some numerical results how
to do that
so we replace that by discretization
usually by
monte carlo quasi-monte carlo it's
questionable if it's useful or not to do
that
okay so i again i need only two
because of this because of this
assumption
i need the only marginal distribution
but it's still a random vector
it can make half dimension hundred okay
here also at every i have to solve
the optimization problem
how i thought it's a good question even
in a linear case
why i saw when i in the beginning why
i wrote linear even on linear cases
we'll see it's
very non-trivial question
now what is extremely important is here
right as we'll see in linear case
this function are convex with respect to
the decision
variables and for example in any case or
more general some points
for optimization in this area
convexity is extremely important
more important than a smoothness of
differentiability much more
so what how one can use that
this is what i said okay
and so this is how one can put it and
therefore
large let me also say that
trying to make discretization of the
decision variable of state doesn't
it's it doesn't go much anywhere
if they say if it is one dimension
you probably make discretization of that
and then it becomes finite vector
but the number of digitization points
you need to approximate reasonable
weight
they're all exponential dimension of x t
so for even for three already it doesn't
work
this discretization so one has to do
something else
okay so again remember when we talk this
conversation one
make this one talk about desperation of
the process of
continuous distributions but he
and this we have to do we'll see that
all right but they're also displacation
of the decision variables of the state
space doesn't happen
for only very simple cases
now uh they so
so the strong indication
that again computer genetically
multi-stage computational problems are
intractable
even if one want to solve that with not
very high accuracy
okay so what can one do
realistically and there are different
ways how people try to address it now
i i'll talk about one particular way
that's just now
there's several ways in other words
one need to do some type of
approximation
the question what is the reasonable
approximation right
can the error of the approximation can
be made and so on and so on
i will talk about that
it will be important now that the
constraints are linear one can do more
general but
it's sufficiently general here you can
think about that the convex function of
just
even linear functions please remember
that eventually right what i
interested in is a first stage solution
typically because this policy that i
have here typically people recalculate
as information is coming in
now can one do anything about that
now the what became very popular
recently
is a cutting blend time method
which has a very long history
it goes originally to this this you see
this how
60 years ago for deterministic problem
this is a very simple algorithm for
conics problems
that one only need to know how to
deterministic
convex problems and let's generate
cutting planes at cutting planes i don't
know if you saw that if you
work on optimization i'm sure you saw
that type of things
and this very primitive algorithm which
was improved enormously by all types of
methods
at the moment in deterministic
optimization with when
you for custom planning probably the
best method is level method
due to nester of nanoroski
le marshal or trust region will already
make
huge improvements
so worst case complexity of that is bad
and it's understandable now
this was extended to in some
this cutting plane made it extended to
some place
to this english paper the multi-stage
and in the paper it was considered
basically fine now it was
in terms of scenarios mainly late
extended more
and then it was uh this this was this
paper which became
very well known at the beginning nobody
really paid much attention to that
because it was
developed by engineers in brazil and
then it was on paper but then it became
now it became very very popular because
sometimes
it can solve the problem with reasonable
accuracy okay so how it works i don't
have much time to talk all the details
but
basically the basic idea is rather
simple
okay remember this we have this this
genomical equations here okay
and this is our convex function it's
certainly true
if this this objective uh this context
with respect to xt
and say we have linear constraints so we
approximated by
piecewise linear function cutting planes
we approximated how unapproximated
one can look at as a particular case of
approximate dynamical problem
[Music]
by adding more and more cuts right
you only choose some points
at every stage these are usually called
trial points
going backward in time and
every time at the trial point this is
your current approximation
of your we shall give you lower value
it's below it's cutting plane
or supporting playing diagnosis right
and when they one choose some additional
point
when that would turn and add to that
cutting employee
solve this a computing sub gradient of
that
for that one it's not difficult to show
one need to solve the dual problem
and it's a linear problem why it's
linear
this every time one solve linear problem
why it's linear because this is given
by maximum of
linearifying functions these are linear
constraints so it's possible to write as
a linear problem
so one going backward in time adding
more and more cuts
and then one choose new trial points
and go in this in circles how to choose
the trial points
every time it's a good question
one possible question is that
one possible approach is therefore first
of all
let's see that this is so-called true
cost of growth functions right this is
lower approximation
by construction and this is piecewise
linear function
the maximum of a fine functions
now every time
every time i we constructed this
functions somehow we generated the
policy
we don't have the generator policy for
truth this for true distribution before
discretized distribution
how it works we simply go backwards in
time
right and every time we solve this
problem
okay for replacing this
we replace the true cost of the function
by its approximation so we define the
policy rule is human it's
possible to solve because every time
it's linear
right if it is not too large it's
possible to solve it
it's a you think you can think about
that you go forward in time
generated this randomly generated
this sequence of random vectors and
solve every time and it gave you
solution
and this usually people usually use as a
trial point
going backwards in so
and it gives you a low bound
because this is give the low bound
eventually if you solve is going
backward in time you compute the
value this is value approximation
movement
and they give you upper bound because
every time one randomly
generate the sample path or scenario
it gives a point estimate of the value
of your policy and this can be average
let's
give you stochastic bounds so when it
has low bound
upper bound stochastic and now we can
see the gap between them and give you
some stochastic guarantee how one
solved the problem after discretization
even more than that it can be applied
also to what we call to the true problem
because this also you can apply this
the same policy to the true problem
simply one
generate random sample from the true
distribution not from discretized
distribution
in your upper bound and it's
stochastically because of that giving
low path
so one can estimate the error of your
solution amazingly sometimes
it works and what i mean it works
for huge problems which are absolutely
unaccessible from scenario the number
of scenarios there is much larger number
of atoms in our universe
one can solve the problem with proof
accuracy say four percent
you say it's bad or ten percent
and it's guaranteed usually the
celebrity
quality is much better than that but
it's almost a miracle that one could
solve problems like that
now why
it's not obvious
this is what i say okay this one can
process low and upper bound
now uh this is a question this this
became very popular method
especially in a power generation
and this can be extended to also mixed
integer problems
also it's much more difficult to solve
them linearly sometimes it's
solvent there are many questions about
that which
are really not well understood
in other words why it sometimes works
because
from a generic point of view
right if you even if i have
convex function and i need to
approximate it uniformly
well because my solution is random i
don't know where to hit next time for
different
sample parts number of this generically
number of the piecewise cutting plants
that i need also grow exponentially with
dimension
so why sometimes it solves even my
problems
where the state space has dimension 20.
you say 20 is not much but still
sometimes people claim that they solve
with dimension hundreds of thousands
which i have doubts but this probably
depends on the structure of the problem
so probably
the possible answer to that and it's not
obvious right that we don't need to
approximate this value function
uniformly everywhere so the solutions
that the solutions that really matter
and what happens
they all probably either low dimension
or they only in certain areas we don't
need to approximate the value of
functions positive function
uniformly everywhere it's not possible
or it's not clear and this method when
we do this randomization when we go
randomly generate will probably tell us
where
it's important or proximity and it
depends on a particular problem
a generic answer is no not much you can
do but
it's amazing that some cases we solve
i'll show you examples
why it's a very
it's a very big question
now i i listed here some of the basic
questions to this algorithm which became
very popular
and in fact this is probably the only
one at the moment
that we have for that type of solutions
for that there is even to prove
convergence
it turns out to be technically
non-trivial or
it's quite clear why but what is a
convergence right
from empirical uh observation it seems
that a the complexity of that
draw not maybe not exactly linear but
more or less not much with number of
stages but it will obviously grow badly
with dimension of the state there are
some papers recently were published
that they try addressed but we shall see
so when it doesn't work again you
already solved this problem
nobody don't tell me that somebody
solved that but sometimes it works
why can't anyone
just define this problem when it works
therefore it is say from critical
observations
from experience work sometimes
this from the optimization point of view
of this algorithm
is a primitive cut and playing algorithm
basically in two stages exactly
algorithm the problem with that that as
one add more and more cuts
it's become the solving linear problem
become more and more time consuming
and it explodes so
can one do anything better than this
primitive type of algorithm
so far there is no evidence of that and
the reason for that
is that in deterministic case
right words because in deterministic
case one need to
have good accurate approximation near
the optimal in the beginning you don't
need to have
very far from the optimal beginning one
doesn't need to have
very good approximation of the function
you have quick progress
as you go closer you need to more and
more current approximation
here we don't have it because the
solution
is run itself is random so one can talk
about first stage solution deterministic
but it's absolutely unclear
how more advanced much better algorithms
can be applied it's also this
maybe i also say that in
two states in static case the stochastic
rather than stochastic approximation
type of approach
worked very well in some places it's
absolutely unclear how to do it here
for the mayor for say more than three
stages
there were recent papers by this land
that
they pushed i think to three stages but
for ten states one can forget about it
it's absolutely unclear how to make it
because one has to reconstruct the whole
policy
uh alex yes so could you give us
some uh intuition about what do the dual
variables mean
and also like how can we interpret the
cutting plans
you have this you see
this is original okay so every time
if i knew this function right
and somehow i can keep it on the
computer basically assault knowledge
probably if i can solve
so what we do every time we it's complex
function with respect to x t
we approximated by maximum
piecewise linear functions
we give low approximation of that how we
do that
okay we add more and more cuts today
okay we add more and more cars at
certain points
every time i i want to add i don't know
what the real function is
real so i replace it by this
approximation
we solve this problem and we compute the
gradient
right of this sub gradient of that
if i do sub gradient of that right at
least one
i can add the corresponding supporting
plane
yeah so so this is the intuition for
cutting plans
in optimization right but in stochastic
programming does it have any particular
physical meanings
so i asked these questions because in
markov decision process
the markov decision process could be
written as a linear program
and then there is duality where primal
variables corresponds to
q functions or value functions but dual
variables corresponds to
some occupancy measure on their policy
so there's some
very interesting duality between a
distribution and a value function in mdp
is there something related yes
just one moment i'll it
sorry for this break okay uh
you're absolutely right and if you look
at this original problem
when the number of scenarios is final
linear it's a few you can write think
about it it's a huge
linear programming problem huge
astronomical as a linear programming
problem has dual
no it's standard
[Music]
is
i'm very sorry because my doctor was
good
okay so you're absolutely right
so there's a dual problem the question
how to use it
and uh we have a i hope i have time now
to show how you can use dua
is that your question
uh yes this is your question yes
question here
understand what does the dual program
mean physically
yes i will try to show you here the door
problem
is just for this one problem for how to
compute subdragon no this is a classical
in
linear programming that you carry
computer supply for that you need to
solve the dual problem
okay i hope i'll have time to do that
okay
okay so uh notice how this algorithm
works
it go forward and backward okay
and hopefully it converge
now uh so this is a
this is a this natural questions about
this which are not
do don't have good answers
uh this uh there's recently some papers
a couple of papers appeared about that
seems to be good progress
it's this uh this is some intuitively
clear that how wide it should be but
there's no
simple theory or anything probably time
delay depending on the problem
it's not clear at all how to use this
more advanced
algorithm and let's say there have been
attempts to do that
it's not convincing and it doesn't seem
to be working
uh another interesting question
is that what i said several times
right is that uh it's not natural
here that data process is independent
from stage to stage
very often it has some type of
autocorrelation structure
actually but at least it's markovian for
example if we if we model the time
series if
is the time series it can be marked we
use mercury
how to do that in some cases it's
possible to do but there's a cost of
that
the state space increasing and there is
a still a lot and not clear about that
okay now uh
i'm not sure i should talk about that
because
you know what uh i'll come back to that
about half time
about risk reverse distribution reverse
risk of growth
it turns out that this type of this
algorithm can be extended to
distribution robust resource approach
with almost no additional cost of that
surprisingly but there are problems with
that i don't know
for that i'll have to talk about all
this theory
what is the distribution robust risk
reversal i don't
think i will have enough time to that
uh it's possible to write still to write
equations
i probably will come back to that if i
will have
time
okay i i'll come back to that before
first time okay now
uh one of the questions that was
asked what is really the
value of solving multi-stage problems
this is
classical example that became now
classical example
is that we solve this
problem with hundred and twenty stages
it wasn't a it was a for period ten
years on monthly basis
it was a problem of this power
generation
maybe i'll have time to talk about that
120 stages is a lot
uh should one really do that
now in many
when one try to solve multi-stage
problems of that and generally
usually it's not stationary
but very often it has sometimes
periodical behavior the problem has
periodical behavior
know this example that if i'll have time
to i will talk about that
this is how much rain or influence
or what influence will be per month so
there's a
historical data and that's supposed to
be more or less
at least stochastically repeated every
year
right so there's a period of 12 more or
less
how this model usually things like that
it's not stationary but nevertheless
there is
some type of behavior here of this
structure here
so now i probably will talk something
much more familiar to you
let's say and this seems to be another
thing that works
quite well so
i wrote a general this uh it is
functional but you can think about that
it
is expected really and
what appears here this is what
is you probably all will know now
infinite
horizon and this is discount factor
i think about that as expected value
it's also possible to formulate for risk
but let's do this for expected value and
we solve again probably linear type of
this we have linear holding
now very often what happens
that the random this random process data
process has periodical behavior this is
how it's modeled
of seven period say 12 months
so in other words it repeats this
every 12 months stochastically it
repeats itself
and then we can think about we look at
the infinite horizon
we've discovered a factor versus this is
not start
okay if we do this like that
okay then your value function
we it's this region still we still
assume stage-wise independence here
but even then it's difficult to solve
the value function
of that are the same because we look at
the repeat itself it with period
m and then
it's possible to write this belmonic
what is called
bellman operation so a berlin equation
of bellman operator
which in this particular case will look
like that
no again you can think about that
expected value it's possible to write in
general for risk functional
maybe i'll have time to talk about it
so what happens if this if we do that
we reduce
a say 120 stages
to 12. one of the problems when we look
at
this this time horizon
uh why i need so many ways they needed
so many stages
because uh if we don't do that there's
there's a what is called
end of horizon effect they are the
algorithm
at the end say well use all your
resources it doesn't care what happens
afterwards
because that too they they use it
originally it was planning for five
years and then next five years was given
just because of the final horizon effect
that it will not
although it will not suggest use
everything now
because after its time is stopping there
now when we do it like that it's this
equation of time
it's automatic because it repeats
repeats periodically
and it turns out that it's still
possible to
apply to that this sddp method this
cutting type of
methods also there's some questions
about that how they
like that and it works quite well
first again for first stage
which is really imp for first couple of
stages
is the same solution as solving all
these 120 stages
but it it's computationally it's
much reduced computational effort
enormously
and it seems to be working now now uh
of course this is the period m here
right
one can take period m equal to one
in other words one just then it will
become the standard way this is how
people do it
in i suppose they say it will be this
classical belmont equation
which people use here
this is not i don't think this is
something new here
uh from this point of view and but
what is new year that that still
the method it wants to be working and
working quite well
this cutting playing time methods
okay so one can also write this write
this bellman equation
and there's a bellman operator that's
possible to write this
as you all know of course it's because
or it's
because of the periodical behavior
it is a it's defined on the product of
this
type of man this is how it looks in this
particular case
and then by more or less standard
methods
it's possible to show all right this is
a
this is a contraction method where this
is discount factor
where this is a this subnorm of that
it's one take this all
over all of them because of that if one
define an
appropriate space bounded functions it
has a unique fixed point
and uh no this one can think about that
in classical way
now
there's several interesting questions
about that this is a
again this is something at least in this
area where i talk with something very
recent
surprisingly it works and there various
questions relate
to them
suppose for the moment we have this
period one for simplicity
e we need to still
we have this the corresponding process
here which repeat itself but it has
continuous distribution
we need to discretize that suppose by
sampling
by using this discretization we
approximate the true cause-to-growth
function of that which is a solution of
the corresponding
bellman equation by this sample
approximation
it's not difficult to show that one has
this type of inequality
this is super normal
this second bar we know we know what a
bounce that uniform balance of that is
basically what i showed you before
and then the coefficients coefficient
here
what really interesting and
strange maybe even strange
what is the sample complexity of that
even if we're m equal period
m equal to what you see this
in applications that i'm talking about
that i'll show you in a moment
this discount factor very close to what
it's 0.99 something okay
very close to one so it's a very large
number
what typically happens uh so
what is this for fixed gamma
for fixed discount factor we because we
know what is the complexity of that we
have a
standard estimates of this sample
complexity
but what is the very interesting
questions which i don't know
simple answer what happens when it
reflects when it approaches one
now uh
what this bounce suggests that
relative error will grow
like 1 divided by 1 minus gamma y
because uh no as gamma
as this discount factor starts to
approach 1
right the value of that grows
also like one divided by one minus gamma
it's very easy to show using this
this geometric series sum of geometric
series
because of that the theory modulus
says which theory what we have
says that relative error as
a function of the n of the sample
size should be
proportional to 1 divided by 1 minus
gamma
what is interesting from and this is we
still have very limited number of
experiments it works much better than
that
why i'm not sure
so this is a question so there's a
number of questions here this complexity
of that one of these this
specific question for this approach what
happens with sample complexity
when this approach works and this is
important for applications
at least applications that i mean i will
show you example
so it's one of the questions
now about the duals this is you ask me
about the duals is exactly what i will
talk
now
if we look at this problem this is
linear problem
[Music]
suppose we have finite number of
possible
realization of that fine number of
possible scenarios
in principle i can write that as
one linear program
this is everything is fine
theoretically it will be huge but it's a
linear problem it has
dual can i
use the dual for calculations what
happens in for example in this approach
that a classical sddp method is cutting
plane methods give
balance it give the lower bound
which given by the lower approximation
and gives stochastic upper bound
stochastic
one way to compute this low bound
standard
but the upper bound is that one it
eventually one
solve this infinite horizon problem here
so i can cut it somewhere i can take
this
carpet to something it's not difficult
by geometric series to estimate what
will be reminder of that
all right and then i can approximate it
the problem is
that when this is very close to one
right i need to take the corresponding
very large
number here to this
to error to remind the error to make it
small that i can disregard it or control
so when this upper bound this
what we stand up bound what we had
before
does not work when this discount factor
is let's say 0.99
and this is a this is a
example that we have to deal this is re
this is really it's even sometimes
even more nine nines nine
okay now
what is interesting and it actually it's
all was known for quite
long time but it was not applied
it's possible to look at a dual problem
remember it's a huge linear problem
right one hope to write dynamical
equation for dual problem
and it's possible all right
and it's possible to write it in a
dynamical way
it's usually underwrite lagrangia and
then
in change look at the saddle poor and
change my mind
and it will look like this the dual
what is this what is a little bit
surprising here
then one let's look at a dual problem
and
it's now the first this is our lagrange
multi-class
could do a problem one can write
they do not decompose into in
in a primal problem when you saw that
it decomposed for every possible
scenario
for every possible discretization
marginal distribution
here they do not no what can i do it is
like that
right nevertheless
one can do similar things is humanness
independence stage wise independence one
can write dynamical equation
when you have discretization it's like
that and one can
solve that by using this
cutting planes similar to what we did
for
primal problem one can compute the value
function it's a little take a little bit
more time
because it doesn't decompose depending
on how large the problem is
what is possible to do
and it works
why
i don't
it works even when the
discount factor is very close
to 1.
i have few minutes left
okay this is a became a famous example
probably some of you probably saw it
many times
all right that's when we started to work
about 10 years ago but
it was a brazilian power system
generation
and that was mainly from uh
the electricity was merely produced from
water power new exchange and now from
what i understand but
the example itself it became classical
it was uh the system this is the best
that they have many of them
it's that time it was aggregated in four
different regions
so uh the state space
was four-dimensional and there
was a the uncertainty was influence
every month
it was a on higher level it was
a monthly basis and that was originally
was supposed to be
playing for 10 years because the monthly
basis
so it resulted in multistage problem
of 120 stages
now there and how this this
influence of the water coming every
month was
modeled as a certain periodic
autoregressive process
on monthly basis based on historical
data and this model was built
and that the decision was every decision
variable how much water use
every month on high level and it was
disaggregated
weekly my early trade and it's it's
complicated but this is at least what
the general okay
so uh it's obvio it has periodical
behavior
because there were dry reason even and
the
rainy reasons on monthly basis
and this is what we tried to solve in
the beginning
what was a it was this first of all the
model was
it was built certain type of model of
autoregressive process periodically
because it's monthly basis then it was
discretized
a 100 a it was the original distribution
were continuous coming from time series
model
at least we discretize it using hundred
samples per stage and what
is stabilized around that because one
can compute upper and lower bound
and this is a well it was also
used with the risk trying to control the
risk risk
is that here that one doesn't want
it's on monthly basis so risk is a
the cost of electricity for consumers
should not go through the roof every
month and they depend how much water
they can use
because using water almost free
otherwise if they don't if there is not
enough water one has to
use some very expensive type of gas and
oil and so on
and these were solutions and it turns
out
this the
we also saw that using this
using this periodical behavior and
they're very similar solutions of that
it was natural
depend on a discount factor so
if you want to use this discount factor
this is
imagine it's it's a period of 12. so
after if you take
the power 12 it's almost zero but
if one they really use this discount
factor why
because they give 12 percent on my own
yearly basis so it's you see it's very
very close
to one so
for that they are stunned with upper
bound
did not work because one has to estimate
the
tail of infinite this is too much a this
numerically didn't work
so we tried to use that
using this type of their
dual bounds and what surprisingly well
even for that now uh you see it's a
still four state variables here
what happened there is the first order
regressive process
gave reasonably good approximation of
the data
because of that a one add it is uh
because of this autoregressive structure
one had more four variables to stay
so originally it was for
eight state variables now i think they
decided to go
to ten regions and it's not clear how to
work and all that there are many many
questions about
all me this is probably last thing that
i'm sure i think i will
finish now uh
this is example this is how low bound
works
for this remember this is periodical
problem
with 12 stages which repeat itself
you cannot make discretization here of
the state space
for 12 periods this is low bound which
is monotonically
and give low bound for the true value
for the for the value of the problem
this is for discretization
now in order to solve this upper bound
once of the dual problem you see this
strange thing what happened
is that if one used this language adding
more and more cards
at a certain point there are too many
cuts many of them redundant
you don't know which okay so
because that conversion is quite slowly
when gamma of this
discount vector was very close to one so
the simple idea
here to restart the procedure say
every hundredth iterations for the dual
problem
because how it works one look at this
upper bound for each value function
which current up and then start to add
cuts
so this works reasonably well this type
of procedure by removing
all the cuts is starting it's from new
because that's a little bit
jump up because you start with new using
the current
upper bound and that bone and you can
see that converge
in reasonable way when the
classical one doesn't work at all so
it's still not clear this
there are many questions about that what
is the complexity of that
what is the complexity of computational
algorithm what is the complexity of
uh discretization and so on and so on so
now i don't know
this there's some other things i
probably will not have to talk about it
about stopping time probably i'll have
more time to talk about that
i we i will not
have time to talk about this
distribution of robust
noise somebody interesting we can
discuss that yes
i think this is if our okay this
yes okay so we have
one question from rene carmona so he
says like in the finance industry to get
around with the curse of dimensionality
people usually try to estimate
conditional expectations
using some form of regression or even
neural network fitting so how would that
approach
be useful here it's very interesting
question
and let me tell you the story okay
i didn't have time to talk about this
stopping time
which is a from what i understand is the
classical thing
uh this is this this message that i
talked about here
based on convexity context is everything
okay so some problems are convicts and
some are not
uh sorry for interruption i uh i might
yeah
i wasn't asking about stopping time i
was asking
renee was asking about curse of
dimensionality
and the use of regression
for asking i'm coming okay uh
so uh we looked at
the method that used in finance to solve
the united functions and
in principle we can do the same we're
using pattern planes
and the method and it won't reasonably
work
i'm not sure that we didn't push it far
but it seems that we couldn't compete
with the methods that you used in
regression and that
also it works we have examples i can
show you for this for for example this
particular
all right
i don't know it's all but again nobody
saw of course of dimensionality
uh this in my understanding in this
using the scope and time is what we use
the specific structure is that very much
so
no again i i heard that all types of
talks and especially people say oh we
solve the problem with thousand state
variables
thousands millions of state variables
[Music]
either let's put it this way
or this probably there's some very
specific structure
even so no we did experiments
uh we increased the state space twice
from eight to sixteen but a little bit
artificially in the problem that we saw
and if the how it was constructed was
highly correlated the real dimension
probably much much smaller than
16 people
but the moment you separate them the
complexity jumps enormously
who knows so
when it works it probably works because
the one doesn't need to approximate the
value functions
everywhere why what specific case we
don't know
i don't know if this answer the question
is answer the question
um i think it's the use of functional
approximation
especially neural network is always i
would say like tricky
in terms of theoretical analysis but
also it's harder to compare because to
make
function approximation work or to make a
regression work one would definitely
need
additional assumptions so i think this
is
so i i personally think that this is
really a very interesting
like open problem to think about
it's different way of looking sometimes
it works
we couldn't compete with this this
regression methods that
it's at least these few experiments that
they did maybe this
we didn't push it so far
but this is uh examples that if i
understand correctly are very specific
now there are many possible approaches
now
one approach to use parameterized
to make parametrization of possible
policies
sometimes it's reasonable
so there are still many open questions
yeah and
is it possible to parameterize the
cutting plans
i'm not sure what it means we of course
they are parameterized the cutting plane
say it's
not implants it's uh defined by a fine
number of parameters
it's a linear depending how many
uh people you know they used a very
popular become to use this
fine policies especially in robust
optimization
i didn't talk about it but this modeling
that is a random process is not the only
one possible
okay sometimes it works from what i
understand sometimes it doesn't
nobody knows why at least my impression
thank you so we have uh one more
question from the audience
yes so the question is does it make
sense to use quadratic approximation to
get a lower bound
rather than using a linear one and let's
suppose that we do have strong convexity
which is some nice properties
would it be better to use a better lower
bound
i don't know vincent tried to do this i
am not sure
i don't know if i will see convincing
way of doing that i will change my
opinion
i don't know this is a using this cotton
cut and planes is classical
and it has very clear theory about it
and clear understanding
it's very here we use only convexity of
that
for if using a quadratic approximation
one need to estimate
the curvature that's how strong and then
it's very difficult
i'm not sure i don't know as i said i
don't have answers to all questions
yeah i think just in classical
optimization if we do have strong
complexity
then it makes sense to use quadratic
lower bound not not cutting points but
cutting planes with the quadratic
penalties
and there are faster convergence results
but for classical optimization
so i don't know what is has been tried
in stochastic programming yet
uh probably
what you're saying because people use it
as a penalization
approach trust region correct
not as low approximation not as
approximation by cutting planes
i didn't see any any quadratic type i
don't know maybe i can see
yeah i was talking about just classical
optimization we can solve classical
optimization problem
using dual cutting plane with an
additional quadratic term
yes so when we have strong convex well
the quadratic term
here is coming as a regularization
term correct we can we can think about
it in that way
right it is not that you try to
approximate
your function by quadratic functions
this way quadratic function
no is that where you know it's like
we're attract
uh instead of taking the the supreme the
supreme of a class of cutting prince
we're taking the supreme of a class of
quadratic functions
so as a tighter approximation
i don't know i didn't see this even
deterministic backpackers like them
oh there there is actually
i don't know i can tell i can say that
we have been attempts
to use penalization with this quadratic
terminal this translation table
it's absolutely unbelievable i was
i didn't see any convincing theory about
that
and the numerical experiments as good as
this
particular example i don't know
in that case it will be very difficult
because
it's your value function is complicated
you have no direct
way of even knowing what is that i
i don't it's difficult
yeah so finally like renee carmona made
a remark
that so it seems like it's reasonable to
use multicultural
scenarios because the random process
because i t is not affected by the
controls
so it's like optimal stopping in option
pricing
yeah so so is there like a major
difference
like for example like if the stochastic
process is actually
heavily influenced by our own controls
then it's harder to do monte carlo
simulation is that
the right way to think about it if the
stochastic process itself effect
by our decisions everything that i said
doesn't work they
one of the reasons is that
it destroy convexity even in linear
phase
so all these methods that i said will
not work at all
so this is a big difference and that
i can imagine that the many implications
that
our decisions affect the distributions
clearly
how to deal with that i don't know but
this is what i said will not work yeah
so i think there are like approaches for
example
uh by for example doing some sort of
like multi-colored research
like even if scenarios and actions
uh influence the randomness it's still
possible
to get good heuristic or approximation
algorithms
but understanding convergence and
approximation guarantee for those
algorithms require much stronger
assumptions or sometimes
there's little theory about those
i agree many many open questions i've
listed some
all right let's see if we have okay so
okay just from renee again so renee
agrees
with the comment that whenever the
process
is independent from the controls this is
a significantly simpler a simpler
problem
and there's uh we there's not much more
we could do theoretically
probably once everything is entangled
together it's simpler but it's still
very difficult
of course
this is what we have now i can i don't
claim that i
have answers to all questions not
certainly not
um okay it seems like we have
all the questions answered so far
and uh so uh thank you alex and so
we really enjoy it so we'll stop from
here
and we'll regroup in one hour and so i
think there's like
this guy there are discussions in the in
the chat and in the discord and also in
the gather time
so let's let's uh let's move
uh this discussion like offline from the
zoo
seminar if somebody interested will i
would be glad to talk
many many many there are many still
open questions maybe it's something or
something
all right thank you alex thank you all
very much
okay yeah chaba do you want us add
something
sorry no i i just want to thank again